be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly
what's going on comic nation this is Rob
and as we continue with moving towards
time runs out we pick up now with our
final video before the main time runs
out event then what we're going to be
doing here is we're going to be focusing
on star brand and night mass now the
reason we're discussing both of these
characters in the same video is because
they're closely tied to one another now
again capitalizing on our discussion in
the last video about the builders what
we discuss was that the builders had
positioned a satellite that created
something called a white event now what
the white event does is it allows a race
on any given planet to move into its
next stage of evolution and this
transition is brought about in the form
of five avatars the knight mask is the
first avatar which leads the race into
its new transition the second avatar is
the star brand and the star brand
protects the new race the third star I
guess the third avatar is the cipher and
the cypher teaches followed by the
Justice which maintains order as well as
the Spitfire now one of the things that
we learn is that the satellite doesn't
actually send out a signal on its own
instead there's an overseer of sorts
that monitors all satellites in the
multiverse and when any one race in any
universe is deemed worthy of evolving
the overseer actually commands the
satellite to send out or to initiate a
white event now under normal
circumstances these individuals are
selected to help smooth the transition
of the race with the individuals best
suited for these roles receiving their
respective powers now what we learn is
that due to the fact that the multiverse
is collapsing that what the overseer
ends up doing is he basically sends out
a or I guess so that a command to all
the satellites to initiate a white event
and the result is that on in the
earth-616 universe the mainstream
universe rather than the satellites
sending out the signal or giving powers
to people who are worthy of the powers
instead sends those powers out
arbitrarily and so the result is that a
genetically-engineered person named Adam
ends up becoming nine masks and a
college student named Kevin Connor ends
up becoming the star brand and the other
avatars actually don't end up
manifesting now with regards to the
actual stories or I guess the origins of
these characters
what Hickman gave us were a group called
the gardener's now where the builders
create systems capable
of supporting life the Gardner's create
life on those systems and one of these
gardeners is a being named ex nihilo now
one of the first actions of ex nihilo
was to attempt to create an evolved
version of humans on Mars and the first
being he creates is a person named Adam
and what Nick ex nihilo explains here is
that Adam was created by I guess using a
combination of God particles now we're
not explicitly told what God particles
are with the exception of maybe saying
that they're basically composed of the
fabric of the universe itself but the
fact remains one of them happening here
is that almost immediately after Adam is
created or after he is revealed to us
the actions of ex nihilo have brought
the attention of the Avengers and so
after a short battle the Avengers agree
that ex nihilo can stay on Mars and do
his thing and that Adams going to come
back to earth with them the reason being
because if Adam was designed to be an
evolve version of humans the best way
for him to learn what it means to be
human is to live among humans now while
Adams on earth and what Tony Stark's
basically trying to do is decipher the
language of Adam and once he's able to
do so with the help of Captain universe
what we end up learning is that
according to Adam that the last white
event is coming and so what ends up
happening is that everything is shrouded
and complete white everything goes
totally blank and the result is that
Adam ends up becoming Knight mask
and Kevin Connor is bestowed with the
powers of star brand now what is up
happening here is once Adam becomes
night mask
he immediately learns what it is is
taking place and so what he tells the
avengers after teaming up with them is
that they're supposed to be other
avatars and so what the Avengers a night
mask do is they set out trying to find
Kevin Connor now what we learned about
Kevin Connor is that he was largely an
ignored college student but when he
received the star brand he didn't know
what to do with all this power and the
result was that he had inadvertently
destroyed his entire college campus and
killed 3200 people and so when the
Avengers arrived and began to question
Kevin he started to panic he started to
freak out now the Avengers tried to
subdue him but in the process Kevin
Connor blasted the Incredible Hulk into
the atmosphere
in addition Thor threw his hammer at
Kevin Connor and
connor wasn't fazed by it of course it
not Kevin Connor down but as far as
Kevin Connor indicates to us it was
simply the sheer force of the hammer
more so than the hammer actually doing
any damage to Kevin Connor and so what
is up happening is that while the
situation seems to be escalating and
getting out of control night mask steps
in and what night mask does is he
basically takes a takes Kevin Connor
away he takes Kevin Connor back to Mars
and begins basically explaining to Kevin
Connor what else happening here what he
tells Kevin Connor is that as the star
brand
Kevin Conners role is to protect the new
evolution of this race and so Kevin
Connor has the power to confront any
threat no matter how powerful that
threat is effectively telling us there
is no limit to the amount of power that
Kevin Connor has that Kevin Connor is
basically a character who can now work
reality on a cosmic scale but because of
the fact that Kevin and Connor doesn't
know how to deal with his powers because
he's incapable of coping with his
abilities and because the Avengers don't
quite know what to make of Knight mask
yet what ends up happening is the
Avengers basically lock Knight masks and
Kevin Connor away now this was basically
Marvel removing these characters from
the equation temporarily during the
infinity event that was basically the
purpose of this but what we'll find is
that once we get into time runs out and
we especially pick up eight months later
when we're dealing with the multiversal
Avengers that we're going to see their
characters return and that Knight mask
and star brand are going to become
extremely important especially when we
get into the battle with the beyonders
towards the end of time runs out without
being said we're going to go ahead and
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and I will catch you guys later
you
the green band